that's why it's so interesting to see
mike tyson's make the switch
it's clear that like whatever that is
however that fight goes he made us
there's a switch of a dif he stepped
into a different dimension
roy jones jr is coming on my podcast
soon and uh you know roy's gonna be on
uh before the fight i'm
i'm so curious to see how it goes down
but genuinely concerned
because mike tyson is a heavyweight and
roy jones at his best was
pounds and um i don't know if roy has
that room in his house mental house of
where mike tyson goes
i don't know i don't know if he has a
rope mike doesn't have a room
he's got an empire in there with the
open side
there's a whole empire in his head and
he's he's in that
firmly you know when he got out of the
weed and and
started training again like you could
see it in him and by the way
physically in person looks spectacular
he looks like a adonis i mean he
looks ready to go
it's crazy yeah watching videos of him
you